- [Narrator] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat music)
- Well, good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen,
and welcome to this lecture.
This is the third lecture in the
HarvEst Distinguished
Women Lecture Series.
For those who don't know you,
my name is Fiona Doyle.
In addition to being a
Professor in Material Science
and Engineering, I'm the
Dean of the Graduate Division
at Berkeley.
The Graduate Division
has a proud tradition
of managing the Berkeley
graduate lectures.
We cover eight lectureships in all.
Each has a distinctive endowment history
and a distinctive theme for the lectures
that are delivered under their auspices.
The different programs
have brought a variety of
incredibly distinguished
visitors to Berkeley since 1904.
So this goes back well over 100 years,
really building on the principle
that a great university
is the repository and
the center of knowledge
that should be made available
to the general public.
What's I find very interesting about the
HarvEst Distinguished
Women Lecture Series,
which is the newest
edition to our collection,
is that rather than
choosing a particular theme
for the lecture, the common
theme for the three lectures
has been distinguished women who, in fact,
have been very, very different
in their contributions to the world
and their overall impact.
The HarvEst lecture name
comes from the first names
of our lecture benefactors,
UC Berkeley alumni,
Harvey Lee and Esther Ma,
both of whom earned their
undergraduate degrees
in economics at Berkeley
before pursuing MBA degrees
at Harvard and Columbia, respectively.
Both Harvey and Esther have gone onto
accomplished international
business careers.
Esther is the founder
of the public relations firm, Prestique
and is author of four books.
She was featured in the
2011 book Ladies Who Launch.
Harvey is the Vice Chairman
of Golden Real Estate
Financial Holdings, Limited.
Although the couple
are based in Hong Kong,
I'm delighted that they
are here with us today
and along with their beautiful daughters.
And on your behalf, I wish
the family happy new year.
So we're very lucky that they've joined us
during Chinese New Year.
So, with that, it's my pleasure to
invite Esther up to lectern
to provide a few words
on her perspective on
distinguished women.
Esther.
- Thank you, Dean Doyle.
Wow, it's great to be
back at Cal, go bears!
(laughs)
(audience applauding)
So good afternoon and happy
Chinese New Year of the Monkey.
Dean Doyle, Miss Frances Dinkelspiel,
Miss Deirdre English, and alumni,
faculty, students and
distinguished guests.
It is my and Harvey's
honor to be here again
for the third time to present the third
HarvEst Distinguished
Women Leader Lecture.
Well, I always like to
start with this poem
that was actually unveiled
during our wedding back in 1994.
So here it goes.
On a bright sunny day
under the Sather Gate,
two Berkeley freshmen met by fate.
Dot, dot, dot, dot.
Nine years of sharing,
nine years of caring,
love has come of age
and true love and mutual trust
will allow the 1985 vintage
to yield a fruitful harvest.
So, indeed, HarvEst got married
nine years after they met
under the Sather Gate.
But it took them a little while
to HarvEst the two little
ones, Quisha and Tiqa.
Took us 11 years.
And Quisha was born in 2005,
while Tiqa was born in 2007,
because I actually had a
couple of multiple miscarriages
within four years before that.
But, anyway, you know, ever
since I became a parent,
Harvey and I both realized
the importance of education,
philanthropy, giving back to the community
and really nurturing a young
generation of future leaders.
And so that's why when Dean Andrew Szeri
approached us five years ago
to offer us this opportunity to endow
lecture series, we immediately accepted
the invitation without hesitation,
because this distinguished lecture series
resonates with our
philanthropic philosophies,
being in education,
leadership, philanthropy
and also in the arts and the athletics.
So if you look in Instagram
under my name, Esther Ma Lee,
you will notice that label
myself hyper-momtrepreneur.
Well, I always call myself a full-time mom
and a full time entrepreneur,
having been running my
own business for 20 years
and also now being a mom for 10 years.
I think I kind of take pride
in being able to achieve
that work-life balance,
which gives me a sense,
great sense of gratification.
So my typical day would be
sending Quisha and Tiqa to school at 7:15,
have a quick breakfast
and then workout for
one-and-a-half hours to two hours,
go into the office, have a business lunch,
and then run some errands,
and then pick up the girls at 3:30.
And then I always request
my clients to do events
after 4:45, because that's when the kids
are in their after-school activities.
And then after the event, we'll
either go home for dinner,
look after their homework,
or study with them,
or once in awhile, go out with Harvey
on wine dinners, so on and so forth.
Weekends are always spent
on family gatherings
or some kind of a sports competitions.
But why distinguished women?
Because I'm, myself, I'm a great fan,
great supporter of women courses.
Back home, I'm on the
Zonta Club, which is a NGO,
consisting of women executives.
We all joined force to
help underprivileged women.
I'm also one of the founding members
of the Golden Bauhinia Women
Entrepreneurs Association
and we established scholarship and
a lot of mentoring programs
for aspiring women entrepreneurs.
And I'm also very actively involved
with a women's foundation which
focuses on a lot of research
on issues such as gender
equality and work-life balance.
And they've been getting a lot
of government support lately.
And also I'm volunteering for
Women Helping Women Foundation,
which focuses on helping
marginalized women,
especially those who
experience domestic violence
and domestic abuse.
And on the lighter side of life,
I'm co-founder of Femme du Vin Society,
a women wine society.
Every month we organize wine tasting
for wine education and
networking opportunities.
So when Dean Doyle told me that this year
our speaker's gonna be
a little bit different,
half-different, because the first year,
as Dean Doyle mentioned,
Mrs. Harriet Fulbright
gave a inspiring speech on
international education.
And last year, Professor Laura Tyson,
who happened to be Harvey's first
economics professor,
gave an inspiring speech
on women and the world economy.
And this year, we are so excited
because Harvey also happens
to be in the wine business.
In fact, his boss is the owner
of a Napa Valley vineyard
by the name of Sloan Estates.
And Jenny, I believe, the GM
is making her way down.
So we are really excited that today
our guest lecturer, in fact, is a renowned
author of a best-selling book
called Tangled Vineyards,
so all you need to know
about what happened
in Napa Valley vineyards.
So, without further
ado, I'll let Dean Doyle
make an introduction of
our guest lecturer to you.
And stay tuned for the interesting lecture
as well as some wine
tasting after the lecture.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much, Esther,
and to you and Harvey for your generosity.
So without further ado, we'll
move onto the main event.
I'm very pleased to
introduce Frances Dinkelspiel
who is an award-winning
author and journalist.
She's based in Berkeley,
which is wonderful,
since we'll learn in a second or two
that she's a Stanford graduate.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
I promised her I'd make a dig about that.
And we thought that
a very engaging way to
organize this afternoon
was as a conversation,
rather than a lecture, as such.
So Frances will be in
conversation with Deirdre English,
a lecturer in our graduate
school of journalism here.
And they're going to discuss
how power, money, gold
and wine all contributed to
the making of California,
then and even today.
And that covers I think at least one
of the favorite themes of
many people in this room.
So I'm certainly looking forward
to the conversation immensely.
Frances has delivered
more than 200 lectures
on the history of California,
including the role the Jews made
to the development of the state.
In 2009, she co-founded Berkeleyside,
with which many of you,
I'm sure are very familiar,
an online news site that has since
twice won the Best
Community News Site Award
from the Northern California Society
of Professional Journalists.
In 2013, Dinkelspiel helped created Nosh,
another of my favorite themes, (chuckles)
a website about the food
scene in the East Bay.
As I mentioned, Frances is a graduate
of Stanford University and
The Columbia University
School of Journalism.
She began her reporting career
at the Syracuse newspapers
in upstate New York
and then moved to the
San Jose Mercury News.
She's written for the New York Times,
the Wall Street Journal,
the Los Angeles Times,
People Magazine, San Francisco Chronicle,
San Francisco Magazine, and more.
Her first book, Towers of Gold:
How One Jewish Immigrant
Named Isaias Hellman
Created California, was
a San Francisco Chronicle
best seller, a finalist
for the Northern California
Book Awards, and was the
Best Book of the Year
named by both the San Francisco Chronicle
and the Northern California
Independent Book Sellers Association.
Her most recent book
appears to be getting similar acclaim,
Tangled Vines, as Esther mentioned,
but the subtitle is truly intriguing,
Greed, Murder, Obsession and an Arsonist
in the Vineyards of California.
And this is a New York Times
and San Francisco Chronicle Best Seller.
Deirdre English is a
former editor-in-chief
of the award-winning and
influential Mother Jones Magazine.
She was a founder of one of the first
women's studies programs in the US
and it's taught at several
colleges and universities.
She has written and edited work
on a wide array of subjects
related to investigative reporting,
cultural politics, gender studies,
and public policy.
She's been with Berkeley's
Graduate School of Journalism
since 1997.
So please join me in
welcoming Frances Dinkelspiel
and Deirdre English to the stage.
(audience applauding)
Great and welcome.
- Thank you.
- I'm so looking forward
to hearing (drowned by distance).
- Thank you.
- Well, (chuckles) gold leads to money,
leads to power, leads to wine.
(audience laughing)
So it won't be hard
for us to hit on all those topics.
And obviously we fit very comfortably
under the rubric of the HarvEst moniker.
And in celebration of you as a
outstanding woman leader and author.
So let's just plunge right in.
I've really enjoyed reading
both of these books.
I think they're extraordinary,
Towers of Gold, the story
of Frances Dinkelspiel's
great-great grandfather, Isaias Hellman,
and the bold sub-head in the
creating of California is something
we'll ask you to defend.
And that's a wonderful book that is
a business history of California
and an interesting way into
those of you who haven't
studied California history
in great depth, it's an
actually quite an interesting
way to look at it,
because it goes from the Gold Rush
up unto almost contemporary times.
It's very recognizable
and it covers everything
from land development
to the development of banking and finance.
And then Frances, in her second book,
kind of takes something that
began in the first book,
Towers of Gold, but
that she really explores
in Tangled Vines, her second book,
which is that her
great-great-grandfather, Isaias Hellman,
invested in a vineyard,
in Cucamonga Vineyard
in Southern California
when he was there.
And, eventually, Isaias Hellman moved
from Souther California
to Northern California
and the wine industry also moves
from Souther California
to Northern California,
for different reasons,
but they remain tangled.
So we will be talking
more about win industry
and the dark side of the wine industry,
which Frances gets into in great depth,
the labor exploitation,
the fraud, the greed,
the arson, the criminal behavior
and the threats that continue to this day,
the fraudulent marketing of some wines.
So it's a interconnected history.
I think you've masterfully
woven all of these threads together.
And we agreed that
instead of just focusing
on Tangled Vines today, we'll try to do
a little bit of a timeline
through both of the books
so that we'll start with
talking about Isaias Hellman
right from the very beginning
and then weave it into the current book.
So let's just start with talking about
Isaias Hellman himself and as we were,
just a few minutes ago.
He was very young when
he came to this country.
Who was he?
- So Isaias Hellman was
born in Reckendorf, Germany,
which at the time was part of
Franconia, one of the states of Germany.
It later became part of Bavaria.
And he was a Jewish boy who was born
to a family where his father was a weaver
and his uncle was a cattle trader.
And Jews in Germany were not
accorded full citizenship.
And although the town
that Hellman lived in
had the Catholics and the
Jews had good relations,
it became very clear by the
middle of the 19th Century
that the future for
Jews was not in Germany.
And there had already been a
migration of a number of Jews
leaving central Europe to
come to the United States.
But when the Gold Rush hit,
it completely accelerated that emigration.
And so Hellman came to
the United States in 1859.
And even though that was 10
years after the Gold Rush,
it's still considered sort of part of
the Gold Rush emigration.
- And he was 17-years-old?
- He was 16-years-old
when he came.
- 16 and had had
a little bit of secondary education, but--
- Not not much.
- Not a college education
or anything like that.
But he was a European, he was a German.
And he came from if
not a bourgeois family,
certainly he had seen bourgeois life,
he'd seen city life, he
knew what banking was.
- Well, yes, he had...
You know, the town that he lived in
only had 900 people living there.
But his father was a
weaver and also a peddler.
And I don't know for a
fact, but I imagine that
Isaias accompanied him
to towns in Germany.
He was also sent to secondary school
in a town about 50 miles away Reckendorf.
And so although he
grew up in sort of a
more rural environment,
this was a very intellectual
time in central Europe.
I mean, this was, you know,
Napoleon had been there.
There were all these revolutions going on.
I mean, there was a certain
level of sophistication
that he would've been exposed to.
- So coming to California then,
to frontier California.
That time, Los Angeles had
maybe 4,000, 5,000 residents.
And I love one fact that you said
of 30 to 40 murders a day.
- No, no, not a day.
- Oh, month, a month.
- (laughs) Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- A month.
And so it's the wild west.
And it's a little bit,
must've been for him,
a little bit like going backwards in time
to a rougher time,
but he saw a great deal of opportunity,
as did so many other people.
So it has often said that the people
who really made the great
fortunes out of the Gold Rush
were the people who sold
things to the miners.
- [Frances] Right, right.
- And, indeed, he went into
the dry goods business, right?
- Right, exactly.
So for Hellman and for many
other Jews who arrived,
California was different from any place
they'd ever been before.
And their experiences were
different than the Jews
in New York, because in California,
people were so focused on getting rich
that they hadn't created
social hierarchies
that oppressed a lot of classes.
I mean, there was discrimination against
African Americans and Chinese,
but against Jews, they
were regarded as white.
And it was a frontier, and nothing,
there was no telegraph service
between San Francisco and LA.
There was no train between the two cities,
there were barely any roads.
So essentially it was a
completely undeveloped landscape.
- [Deirdre] And there
was no banking industry.
- No banking industry, right.
- In fact, one thing I
learned from your book
is that California had
actually outlawed banking?
- Yes, so what happened
was there was so much gold
in California, when they wrote
the California Constitution,
they decided not to let
banks operate in the state.
And this is for complicated reasons.
It had to do with something
called the Free Banking Era,
when banks would just print
up their own bank notes
and there was a lot of
people lost a lot of money.
So banks were outlawed.
But that didn't mean
people didn't set up banks.
It just meant they were not regulated,
there was no minimum
financial requirements.
And, in fact, outlawing them probably
made things more volatile in the economy.
- [Deirdre] And more
higher interest rates,
because people had to get
their loans from individuals
typically.
- Exactly.
- So your great-great-grandfather
founded a bank in LA.
And he called it the
Farmers and Mechanics Bank.
- [Frances] Farmers and Merchants Bank.
- Farmers and Merchants Bank.
And he began to loan money to people in LA
at more reasonable rates.
- [Frances] Right, right.
- And he did very well.
- He did very well.
So the bank opened in 1871.
And his business partner was the former
Governor of California,
which was I think a pretty good pick.
And, yeah, so what they did
was that they were able
to normalize the economy
on some level by offering
a lower interest rate.
Interest rates in those
days could be 5% a month.
And so I'm sure many of you've heard
of the huge transfer of land
from the Californios, the
Mexican-born Californians,
to the Americans.
And a lot of that was
because the Californios
borrowed money and put up
their land as collateral,
not really understanding
that compound and interest
was gonna increase their
debts phenomenally.
So Hellman came in, was
able to offer good rates.
And brought capital to the city.
People needed to borrow
money to buy houses
and do businesses.
- And Isaias Hellman
arrived with his brother.
- Yes.
- Herman.
- And that's maybe worth mentioning,
because later they were at odds.
And the stormy personal history being
there are many ups and downs
in business, over time,
and Hellman experienced them,
and sometimes they take a
toll on personal relations.
And it certainly happened
between these two brothers.
But at that time they were
still in business together.
And who else did he go into business with?
- So this is one of the interesting
things about Los Angeles.
It was a society that
really all the groups
sort of mixed together, the Californios,
the Americans, the Europeans.
It was a time, to some
degree, of business harmony.
There were other tensions
around other things.
So his business partners were
Basques, they were Irishmen,
they were Germans, they
were other Americans.
So what had happened,
Los Angeles was a city
that was never meant to be,
because there's no natural port,
there's no navigable river,
there are no minerals.
There's no reason a city
should've grown up there.
But a group of people
sort of banded together
and almost willed Los
Angeles into existence,
including Isaias Hellman,
by really focusing on business
development in Los Angeles.
And that's why the city took off.
I mean, it always--
- So water.
- Water.
- Energy.
- Water and trains.
Those were the two most important
things in the beginning.
Agriculture was a very important product.
And, eventually, of course,
water, power and oil
were really important.
- But first the trolleys, right?
Building a trolley cart
system in Los Angeles.
And then he brought a great deal of land.
And he donated some of that to found
The University of Southern California,
which increased the value
of the land around it.
- [Frances] Right. (chuckles)
- And his mastery of
horizontal integration,
his control of the
trolleys also allowed him
to run a trolley to the campus,
which also helped to increase the value
of the surrounding land.
- That's right, right.
- So he was able to exploit
many different industries,
many different businesses
as well as banking
and have so many different partners.
When did he buy Rancho Cucamonga?
- So Rancho Cucamonga
is the place where...
My book Tangled Vines
talks about this fire
and that destroyed four-and-a-half
million bottles of wine.
And among the wine that was destroyed,
were 175 bottles made by
Isaias Hellman in 1875
from a vineyard in Rancho Cucamonga.
So he bought Rancho Cucamonga in 1870, 71.
So he was very young at that point.
It was before he started
Farmers And Merchants Bank.
But he got together a
syndicate of businessmen
in San Francisco.
And they bought this land
that was being foreclosed upon
because the widow who owned
it couldn't pay her debts.
And, yeah, it was a business deal for him.
- So what was the state
of grape cultivation
and wine-making in
California at that time?
What was the history before Isaias Hellman
ever came to this country?
- So I think a lot of people don't realize
that the California wine industry
got its start not in Napa or Sonoma,
but in Southern California.
And that was primarily because
Father Junipero Serra who
started the mission system,
he brought up grapes from Baja California
and planted them to make sacramental wine.
And he brought up a grape
variety called Mission Grapes,
which were really, really hearty grapes
that did well in the hot
suns of Southern California.
- [Deirdre] Were they already
called Mission Grapes?
- No, no, no.
- [Deirdre] They were named
after the California missions.
- They were named after
the California missions.
That's not their Latin name.
- Well. (laughs)
- Of course, really.
So Los Angeles was known
as The City of Vines
because grapes growing
did really, really well.
And probably by the 1850s
there were 100 vineyards
in the city of Los Angeles,
people making wine for local consumption
and a little bit for export.
The export really hadn't
taken off by then.
But it was a growing business.
So after everyone rushed to California
to make money in the gold mines,
when that sort of ran out,
or it became part of large corporations
started taking over the
gold mining industry,
people looked for other
businesses to go in.
And agriculture was, of course,
one of the most important things.
And a lot of people thought growing grapes
and making wine was a growing industry.
And, in fact, they got tax
breaks for planting vineyards
and things like that.
So when Hellman bought
the Cucamonga vineyard
in 1871, California had a pretty vibrant
wine business going on.
- All this one
type of grape.
- Mostly, it was
predominantly Mission Grapes
until 1890 in California.
And one thing it's important to know
is Mission Grape made really crummy wine.
I mean it was...
And there wine making methods
were not very sophisticated
so even if they had better grapes,
the wine wasn't always so good.
It made sort of dry, it made flat wine
that didn't have a lot of acidity.
There was a push to
bring in other kinds of
grape vines to California,
starting around 1860 there
was a really big push.
And slowly there was a transition from
having Mission Grapes
be the number one grape
to having other varieties.
But that--
- Is that a red varietal or--
- Mission, well, you can
make white wine, too,
from red grapes.
- From the red.
- But, yeah, Mission
is a red grape.
I mean, most of the wine
was port was made from it
and red wine and stuff like that.
- So it all depends on whether
you process the skin or not.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But they did win an award,
such as it may have been,
for the quality of their wine
at the time.
- Yeah, so Rancho Cucamonga
actually became very well known
for the wine it made.
A lot of ways wine makers
made wine taste better
was to fortify it.
They would just turn a ton
brandy into the white wine.
(audience laughing)
And the red wine.
So I found some great scenes in my book
of 49ers trying to make
it over the mountains.
And they were trudging through the deserts
and they were really
tired and cold and hungry.
And one of the first settled
places they came upon
was Rancho Cucamonga.
And they ran into the people making wine
and they sort of just
guzzled this wine down.
And they were very happy after that.
(audience laughing)
But, you know, in the beginning,
the methods that they made
wine were very primitive.
They didn't have a lot of barrels here.
So Native Americans, they
used to string up cow hides
on poles, and Native Americans
would stomp their grapes
and squish the grapes in the cow hides.
And then they would sometimes
have high kind of containers
to ferment the wine.
And eventually--
- [Deirdre] And this
was almost slave labor.
- It definitely was slave labor.
So eventually
they learned how to make better wine.
But for a long time, people
were just cutting corners
to make money.
It was just seen as a product,
not really something that
was particularly special.
- Now, at some point is
it that Isaias Hellman
saved some barrels of wine
that eventually became the 175 bottles
that you finally lost in the arson episode
many decades later?
- I don't 100% know.
So here I am writing
this book about this wine
that was made in 1875.
And I kept asking myself,
"Why does the family
"have this old wine?"
We don't have 1873 wine or
1881 wine, we just have all
this wine from 1875.
- [Deirdre] Or had, right?
- Or had, right, right.
(Deirdre chuckles)
And I think, I figured it
out, which I go to in the book
that it had been a particularly good year
and they must have like
put a few barrels aside
and people forgot about it.
And so when they were
discovered around 1920
after Hellman died, they were then bottled
at that point.
- And they were bottled
because during prohibition,
your family wanted to be able
to take those bottles of wine,
barrels of wine, put them into bottles,
and give them to the family.
- Yes, right, right.
- Right?
So that you could enjoy
yourselves at home.
- Right.
- [Deirdre] Not you, personally.
- Right, no.
(Deirdre laughs)
People don't know that during prohibition,
individuals were allowed
to make up to 200 gallons
of wine a year.
- [Deirdre] That would
be quite an incentive.
- It is quite an incentive.
- For people to go out
and grow their own vineyards
- Well, you know what happened was,
so prohibition came and
you think immediately
that all the vineyards
in California went broke.
But, in fact, they made
more money the next year
because they just shipped their grapes
across the country to New York.
And people were lining up,
the boxcars would come in,
and people were lining
up to buy the grapes
in order to make their own wine.
And so that was a good
business for a couple years.
And then finally it fizzled.
So, actually, what did
lead to the downfall
of the LA-based vineyard
agricultural economy?
- So Los Angeles and Southern California
were the biggest wine growing
areas until the late 1880s.
And what happened was
a blight hit, something
called Pierce's Disease.
And within two years it
had completely decimated
most of the vineyards
in Southern California.
And by that point, there
was rapid industrialization
around Los Angeles.
Land was much more at a premium
than it had been previously.
There was a boom that went on.
And so lots of those
parcels were not planted
back into wine.
And of course it was--
- [Deirdre] The land became
more valuable for housing
than for vineyards.
- For housing, or for oranges.
Oranges became, of course,
the huge crop of Los Angeles.
And so the other thing was the realization
that Southern California was actually
not the best climate for wine,
that Northern California
was a much better climate
to grow grapes, because
it's hot all the time in LA
and Southern California.
In Napa and Sonoma
Counties, one of the reasons
they make such good wine is
they're very warm during the day,
but the temperature drops
pretty significantly at night.
And that sort of combination
is the ideal circumstances
in which grapes grow.
- Big decline in fog now in
Northern California that may
affect the vineyards.
- Oh, sure, climate change
is a huge issue for--
- We're not up to the present yet.
So the wine industry basically collapsed,
or the vineyards collapsed in LA,
not entirely, but to a great extent.
And what is it that
made Isaias Hellman move
to Northern California?
- Well, so Isaias was very
prominent in Southern California.
And he was probably the
biggest banker in Los Angeles.
He just had one little problem,
which was he had a brother-in-law
whose name was Mayer
Lehman of Lehman Brothers.
And I think Isaias felt
that he wasn't as important
as his brother-in-law.
And this is a little
conjecture on my part.
And so I think he wanted
to go to a bigger arena.
So in 1890, he took over
something called the Nevada Bank,
which had been founded by
four Silver Kings in 1875.
It had been once the most largest
capitalized bank in the United States.
But it had fallen on hard times.
And so Hellman bought it
and moved up to Northern
California to take it over.
San Francisco was the center
of California at the time.
There were more millionaires
per capita in San Francisco
than in New York at that time.
It was a very vibrant economy
and he wanted to--
- [Deirdre] What would you
say the size of San Francisco
was compared to LA?
- Oh, LA was very tiny.
It was fewer than 25,000 people in 1890.
And I'm not sure about San Francisco,
but it was probably
more than 100,000, yeah.
LA didn't really surpass San Francisco
in population until after
the turn of the century.
- So the Hellman was, by
this point, a rich man.
And he saw the opportunity
to become much richer.
And he wanted to play
in, move to the big city
and play in the big time.
And he built himself
an incredible mansion.
Tell us about his mansion.
- Well, it was on Sacramento
and Franklin Streets.
It had been built by a
man named Nathaniel Cole
who was a ship's captain.
And it was in an area that at that point
was called the Western Addition,
but they eventually renamed
it sort of Pacific Heights
to make it sound better.
And, yeah, he lived...
And very funny thing is he
lived in this very fancy house
but he lived just like
two doors down from his
childhood friend, a
guy named Isaac Walter,
with whom he'd grown up in Germany.
And just a couple other houses down
was another childhood
friend from the same town,
Reckendorf, the Haases.
Many of you, of course, being at Cal,
you know the Haas family.
So this was really a
fun thing to think about
that here are these men
who'd all come to California,
who'd all struck in rich.
They'd all been playmates back in Germany
and they continued their
friendship in California.
And they used to walk to work together
like a couple times a week,
you know, to Downtown.
- And there were other Jewish
immigrants from Germany
who did very well in America, who invested
in each other's
businesses, became partners
and continued to expand their network.
- That's right.
That's very important sort of...
That's how the Jews
did well in California.
One brother would come
over, raise some money,
bring over another
brother or another cousin.
Some of them would be in San Francisco
or Los Angeles or Portland or Seattle.
And they would all do
business with one another.
Hellman, when he had his dry goods store,
he would buy dry goods
from the Haas family here.
When Abe Haas started a canning factory,
he would ask his Jewish
friends to be investors.
When Isaias Hellmans came
and bought Nevada Bank,
he asked his Jewish friends
to invest in Nevada Bank.
He asked non-Jews as well.
But what happened was it was like,
you know, what's the term?
Rising tide lifts all boats.
And so a lot of the German
Jews and French Jews
who came to California in
the 1850s grew very affluent
together at the same time
because they cooperated with one another
and they helped one
another out business-wise.
- So at the same time,
Hellman had a nephew who he had brought
into his home for seven years,
and who he hired to be the
chief cashier at his bank.
- [Frances] Right.
- But this is where his business interest
and his family interest came
into a tremendous clash.
- Yes.
So this was really fun to find out.
Hellman had a cousin, a
guy named Henry Fleischman,
who he regarded as a son.
And he lived in his house
and he had installed him in the bank.
And one day Henry Fleischman,
Henry Fleischman was a
big, had a high position
in the bank in Los Angeles,
the Farmers and Merchants Bank.
But one day he did not show up to work.
And a sort of scouring
of the books showed that
Fleischman had left with
about $100,000 from the bank.
And he had fled Los Angeles
and no one knew where he was.
And this was apparently at the time
the largest embezzlement of
a bank in California history.
It made all the headlines
all over the state.
There were Pinkerton
guards looking for him.
There were cops at all the train stations
throughout California.
Then he was spotted in Mexico.
And emissaries were
sent to try to find him.
But he managed to escape
with all that money
and he wasn't caught.
- And this caused a
tremendous breach between
Isaias and his brother Herman.
- That's correct.
So Isaias Hellman was very
pig-headed in a lot of ways.
He liked what he liked an
he was very loyal to family.
And he really admired this cousin Henry,
whereas his brother Herman,
who actually was heading
up this bank in LA,
thought Henry, there were
some things about Henry
he didn't like.
And he tried to get Isaias to fire Henry
and Isaias refused.
And it caused a big rift
between the brothers
that would later sort of force them apart.
So he was kind of myopic, Isaias,
he didn't wanna see
what he should've seen.
- Well, we would be surprised
if such a powerful and
successful businessman
as Isaias Hellman did not
have a big ego to match.
- Yes, of course, of course, yes.
- So his brother calls
him something of a tyrant
and doesn't wanna do business
with him anymore after that.
- So one of the things
I found very interesting
in doing the research was that I think
during that era, men who
became very successful
believed that they were successful
not because of their luck.
But they believed that
they were successful
because they were inherently
better than a lot of people
in their world.
And I think this contributed
to this arrogant attitude of Hellman.
I think people like him
thought if someone was poor
it was poor because it was their fault,
it was their mistake.
And it's not that he wouldn't
have sympathy for people
who were down on their luck.
And he did help people
who's down on their luck.
But I think he believed in
a natural order of things.
And since he had risen to the top,
it must mean that he had more brains
than anyone else.
- He felt he deserved it.
(chuckles)
- Exactly, yeah.
- So he then became a very active investor
in the Souther Pacific Railroad.
- Mm-Hm.
So just like about a couple years ago,
I mean, I can't say it's
true for this moment.
People who wanted to get rich
would start Internet companies, right?
Like let's make an app, let's get rich.
Well, back in Isaias Hellman's time,
the way to sort of get rich
was to start a trolley line or to,
yeah, get in the transportation field.
So Hellman built trolleys at a very early
era in Los Angeles.
When he moved up to San Francisco,
he also was involved in trolleys
and he became a financier for
the Southern Pacific Railroad,
both in their local lines in San Francisco
and helping to raise capital
to expand Southern Pacific.
- And then how did become...
How did he get involved
with Wells Fargo Bank?
- So what happened was...
So Collis Huntington
was one of the Big Four
and after he died, his
nephew, Henry Huntington,
hoped that he would be
put in as the head of the
Southern Pacific at that
time, but he was not.
And a couple years later,
a man named Edward Harriman
purchased the Southern Pacific Railroad.
It was a huge business coup.
And at that time Southern Pacific Railroad
actually owned a majority
interest in Wells Fargo Express.
Wells Fargo was known as a company
that delivered gold, delivered passengers.
Its banking functions
were kind of a small part
of its operation.
And when Harriman bought Southern Pacific
he wanted to get rid of the bank.
He was sort of like a dragging asset.
So he was friends with Hellman
and he asked Hellman
if he wanted to buy it.
- [Deirdre] And what year was that?
- It was 1905.
1904.
- 1905.
So the earthquake is coming.
- The earthquake is coming,
yes, yes, yes.
(Deirdre laughs)
- And so he's living
in this neighborhood with his Reckendorf--
- [Frances] Buddies.
- Friends, boyhood friends.
And he's living in this
magnificent mansion
that's has had all kinds of
frescos and beautiful furniture.
And the earthquake comes.
- Right.
So, yes, the earthquake
comes and, you know,
the earthquake itself was devastating.
But it was not as devastating as the fires
that ripped through the city afterwards.
- [Deirdre] The city
didn't have any water.
- Right, right.
- Because the water mains
had been routed through filth
so they ruptured and the city was helpless
and couldn't fight the fire.
So the fire burned for three or four days.
- Right.
And so Hellman had a,
the bank was in something
called the Nevada Block,
it was on Montgomery and Pine Street.
It was a beautiful building.
The fire and earthquake
completely damaged the bank
and, in fact, damaged most of
the banks in San Francisco.
And what this meant was that
there was really no cash
to go around, because
you couldn't open a bank,
a bank vault, after a fire.
You had to let the contents inside cool,
because if you opened the door,
the rush of oxygen would make
all those contents explode.
And so that process took about three weeks
to cool down the vaults.
And a lot of the money was in the vaults.
So San Francisco was this city in ruins.
Nobody had any money to
sort of buy anything,
to do anything.
And so Hellman was one
of a group of bankers
who got together who
decided to sort of take over
the banking system by getting
some money from the mints,
which did survive the earthquake,
and doling it out in small
increments to their customers.
And they didn't even know
who their customers were
and they gave out a lot of money on faith.
And it was sort of helped
ease the transition
from this devastated city.
- And this is also the era of AP Giannini
and the founding
of the Bank of America.
- That's right.
So there's a famous story.
Giannini had only like $80,000.
He didn't even have a ton of money.
But before the fire happened,
He took all his money out.
He put it in a wagon and he
took it down to San Mateo.
And after the fire was over,
while all these others
banks didn't have access
to their money, Giannini
went up to North Beach.
And he was able to give
money out very quickly
to a lot of his Italian customers.
And it earned him a
tremendous amount of...
You know, people were very
happy that they got the money.
And it sort of really catapulted
Giannini's reputation.
And certainly the Bank of
America marketed that story
(Deirdre laughs)
for all it's worth
for many, many decades, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- So obviously now with
California's most significant city
in ruins, it needed to rebuild.
And to rebuild you need
money and you need credit
and you need loans.
So suddenly the banks
that were so new, I mean,
your great-grandfather had only been...
Was he the president,
nominally, the president
of the Wells Fargo Bank?
- [Frances] Yeah, he was
president of Wells Fargo Bank.
- He had only been in
that role for one year
before the earthquake.
Suddenly they're in the
role of needing to loan
tremendous amounts of money
and handle enormous amount of debt
in order to rebuild
San Francisco.
- Right, right.
So this is was one area where the
Jewish networks came in handy.
I know that Hellman had
a lot of relationships
with banks in New York, banks
run by the Lehman family
and other banks that they
could access capital.
And he actually, they had
relationships with other banks.
So there really wasn't
a tremendous difficulty
getting capital in San
Francisco to rebuild.
It was just sort of mostly a
short term kind of dilemma.
- And then there was a
lot more money to be made
in the rebuilding of the ruined city.
And in the meantime, what's
going on in the vineyards
in Napa?
- In the vineyards in Napa.
So the story of wine in California
is very interesting
because it is a story of boom and bust.
I mean, I talked a little
bit about what happened
in Southern California.
At the same time, all
the vines that were dying
in Southern California,
vines in France were dying as well
of this disease called Phylloxera.
And California has always
struggled to sort of prove itself
as a good wine making state.
On the East Coast,
starting from the 1860s,
when the first bottle of wine
was imported from California
to New York, East Coast
people prefer French wine
or Italian wine.
So the story of California is always,
it's always trying to prove itself.
- [Deirdre] In terms of quality.
- In terms of quality.
So when France was hit by this Phylloxera,
all the California wine makers said,
"This is our opportunity.
"We're gonna plant a lot more grapes
"and we're gonna make
the wine for the world,
"because France is dead, it's gone.
"It can't make wine anymore."
So there was a huge amount of planting
that went on in the 1880s.
But, as it turned out,
France figured out how to
resolve its Phylloxera problem.
And as a consequence, in the 1890s,
there was an enormous glut
of grapes on the market.
And the way the wine business
was run in those days
was different.
It wasn't like individual
proprietors did things.
There were wine houses.
There were about 100 wine houses
centered in San Francisco.
And these were like large organizations
that bought wine and
made wine and sold wine
and shipped it in
barrels around the world.
But in the late 1890s,
there was such a glut
of wine on the market
that grapes that once fetched $25 a ton
fetched only $8 a ton.
And so the whole business
sort of collapsed.
And to address that issue,
a group of seven wine houses
got together and formed something called
the California Wine Association,
which grew into a monopoly
that controlled 80% of the
production of wine in California.
It was the muscle behind
the wine making business
in California.
And it fought very hard to do that.
It did a wine war with small producers.
It's squeezed out, you know,
it lowered its price for grapes,
it forced a lot of people out of business.
And in the earthquake,
very interestingly enough,
it lost about 10 million gallons of wine.
And not all of it was completely lost.
There's one great story of
one of the wine houses,
the sewer drain got blocked
during the earthquake.
And the basement filled up with wine.
And after the earthquake,
the CWA convinced the San
Francisco Fire Department
to lay a series of hoses
from that cellar all the
way through the streets
to the port where they off-pumped
all of this cooked wine
into barges that were
then taken to Stockton
and converted into Brandy.
(Deirdre chuckles)
(audience laughing)
They did some fun things.
But the California wine business,
it still had a problem
with its reputation.
California wine was not
considered really good wine.
The CWA did try to create a brand
that was sort of uniform,
it was called Calwa,
they would blend.
They tried to make like
a Coca-Cola of wine
for California wine.
And it did help California's
reputation a little bit.
But, still, in general,
California suffered in comparison
to European wines.
- And wasn't there really
a lot of adulteration
of that wine, too?
The wine that was sold in
those days, in those barrels,
well, what were you really getting?
- Exactly.
Yeah, wine makers, the ones
who planted all those grapes
to take advantage of the Phylloxera,
when the time came to make wine,
a lot of them didn't know how to do it.
And so they would just
add like red food coloring
and chemicals to mask the moldy flavor.
And so all of this contributed
to California's terrible reputation.
- In the meantime,
who's doing the labor in the fields?
- Okay, yeah, this was one
of the most interesting thing
to find out.
So Deirdre talked about that I mention the
dark side of the wine industry.
And, you know, I love wine,
I love to drink wine.
And most of my exposure to
wine before I wrote this book
was going up to Napa,
which is such a spectacular place,
with all those undulating
hills with grapevines
and the blue skies and the fantastic food
and really, really good wine.
But when you look back at
how California wine was made,
it really was...
The history of wine is really
a history of exploitation.
Father Junipero Serra, when
they started to make wine
at the missions, they
used the Native Americans
who'd converted to
Christianity as their labor.
And once those Native Americans
converted Christianity,
they were chattel for the missions.
They weren't allowed to leave.
They weren't allowed to
work on their own schedule.
They were really sort of put to work.
But interestingly enough,
the Americans treated the
Native Americans worse
than the Franciscan missionaries.
The very first law passed in California,
before it even became a state,
was something called the
Indian Indenture Act.
And there was a big labor
shortage in California in 1850
because of the Gold Rush.
So the legislature passed this law
which enabled any white person
to identify a Native American
as either drunk or indolent.
And that would mean that
that Native American
was subject to arrest by
the Sheriff or a marshal, and fined,
and most of those Indians
could not pay their fines.
So the marshal would then
sell off that Indian's labor
to the highest bidder for
a week period at a time.
And the marshals would pocket
a percentage of that money.
And the municipalities
would pocket a percentage
of that money.
So really in the starting from the 1850s
through the 1870s, the
California wine business
was developed on the
backs of this slave labor
of Native Americans.
And they eventually died out
because they were so brutally mistreated.
- So after the Native American
workers tragically died out,
then what did the vineyard owners do?
- Well, they turned to the next group,
which was the Chinese workers.
So the Chinese had come
over in huge numbers
to work on the railroads.
And the Transcontinental
Railroad was completed in 1869
And all of a sudden, there
was this huge pool of labor.
And a lot of vineyard
owners did not like using
the Native Americans because
they were very susceptible
to alcohol and needed
a lot of supervision.
And the Chinese, in
contrast, were self-governing
and they were very, very hardworking.
And I think what is not very well-known
is that the Chinese really started
agriculture in California,
including in the vineyards.
They were the people who
planted the grapes, who
cultivated the grapes,
who made the wine.
And the same is true
for lots of other crops
in California.
- But they didn't have
the opportunity to have ownership.
- No, no, no.
They were workers for hire.
I mean, the amount of
prejudice against the Chinese,
I mean, there were no laws saying that
Chinese people could not own the land,
but they were very mistreated.
And the amount of bias and
prejudice against the Chinese
was extraordinary.
And, of course, I think it was 1884
the Chinese Exclusion Act was passed.
Which prohibited Chinese
immigration into California.
Yeah, so the Chinese
was the next, you know,
wave of worker.
And that eventually gave away to
Mexican and Central American--
- Mexican farm workers and--
- Workers, yeah.
- [Deirdre] Yeah, migrant workers.
- Right.
- Well, so in the meantime,
what is happening with
the quality of the wine
and how did wine come to
be stored in this warehouse
that you talk about?
- So we have to sort of fast forward.
So prohibition came,
completely devastated the
California wine economy.
Certain vineyards and wineries did okay
because they could sell sacramental wine
to synagogues an churches.
For awhile a lot of wineries sold grapes,
they shipped them east.
But, eventually, most of the wineries
had to shut down.
And prohibition was lifted in 1933.
And, really, even by the late 1960s,
California had fewer vineyards operating
than they had prior to prohibition.
And Americans were drinking sweet wine.
They didn't really like table wine.
And all that changed when Julia Child
came on the scene and Jackie
Onassis came on the scene.
And vets who'd fought in World War II
started to think about drinking wine
like they'd seen in France.
And so starting in 1967,
California wine industry really took off.
And it's been sort of an upward trajectory
most of the time since then.
And so my modern day story sort of starts
probably around then.
There was a man named Mark Anderson
who was born in Berkeley in 1948.
He came from a family who lived
in the Claremont District.
He went to John Muir School.
He was a nice, average kid.
And he moved to Sausalito
to work on the house boats
in the early 70s.
And then he eventually
made his way to Hong Kong
and then to Japan where he
lived for a number of years
and he fell in with a group
of very rich Japanese businessmen
who liked to travel around the
world having wine adventures.
And Mark learned a lot
about wine from them.
And then he came back to the US
and he did a lot of things,
none of them successfully.
But in 1999, he started
a wine storage business,
where he set up a facility where he was
storing people's wine,
because wine needs to be kept
at a certain temperature.
Most people don't have that
facility in their house.
And so Mark did that business for awhile.
And then he realized that he--
- [Deirdre] And this is
where the greed and arson
in your subtitle come in.
- That's right.
He was not a stupid guy.
He figured out he could
make a lot more money
by selling his client's wine
than just renting them space.
So for a period of a couple years,
he would just take his client's wine
and take it around to
various stores and sell it.
And one of these stores was
Premier Cru which--
- So he's in a fix.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- He's stealing his clients' wine.
And I don't know if you've been reading
about the recent problem with Premier Cru,
well, back in 2000, John
Fox, who owns Premier Cru,
he would just take Mark's wine.
He didn't ask for any proof
that Mark owned the wine.
Mark was eventually
charged with embezzlement.
At which point there were these charges
levied against him and
he was in the newspaper.
The owner of Premier Cru then said,
"I don't want your wine, Mark Anderson."
But all Mark did was change the name
under which he sold the wine.
And he continued to sell the wine.
So this is part of what
I get into the book,
just how poorly regulated
the wine business is.
Anyway, Mark was charged with
many counts of embezzlement.
And in a desperate attempt
to cover his tracks
he set fire to the wines'
central warehouse in Vallejo, 2005.
And it destroyed a quarter
of a billion dollars
worth of wine--
- Hoping that he would
get the insurance payoff
and be able to cover his tracks,
that he'd actually sold
so much of the wine.
- And the police wouldn't be able to say,
"You sold your clients' wine."
He would say, "No, it just burnt up
"in that fire."
- It burned up, yeah, right.
- It didn't really work out
so well for him, though.
- It didn't work out for him.
He's now in a place that
doesn't sound so good,
Terminal Island, serving
a 27-year sentence.
- Right.
- But you say that today the wine industry
is still not well regulated
and that there's still fraud in
the wine business.
- Yes, there's a lot of fraud
in the wine business.
So just here in Berkeley,
I've been writing a lot about
this incredible wine retailer
named Premier Cru, which
has been around since 1980.
They did a lot of online wine sales.
They would offer really great
French Bordeaux and Burgundy
at prices that were much
lower than their competitors.
And people would buy the wine.
But then they were often
buying wine futures,
which meant they would buy
wine that was still in barrels,
'cause you can get it for less money
when it's still in barrels,
than when it's bottled.
But a lot of these clients
had been complaining that
wine they paid for was never delivered.
And so there was sort
of this low-level rumble
on a lot of wine boards
about what was going on.
But then just in December, oh, sorry,
in December Premier Cru
shut down unexpectedly.
And then in January, it
filed for bankruptcy.
And just this week, The
FBI announced that it's
investigating it for a Ponzi scheme.
So when they filed for bankruptcy,
they listed $70 million in debts
and seven million dollars in assets.
So there's some $63 million
out there floating around.
Nobody knows where.
So this is just,
I mean, this is just
the most recent example,
but there are lots of
other examples of people
making fraudulent wine
and selling it to some of
the world's most renowned collectors,
and things like that.
There is a lot of dirt
and dark stuff.
- (laughs) Well, it'll
keep you busy.
Well, I want to turn to
questions in the audience
in a minute.
But I just want to comment
that this all began
in some ways with a
personal history for you.
But it turned into California
history and business history
and so many other things.
How do you feel that doing these two books
has changed you or affected you?
Or what has it made you appreciate
that perhaps you didn't before you
embarked on this research?
- Well, you mentioned California history.
I mean, I did study history in college
and I've always loved it.
But it's been really
interesting approaching
California from a
journalistic point of view
in the sense that there's
a lot of great history
that's unknown out there.
I mean, there are,
I mean, I found in the
history of Isaias Hellman
that was a relative.
But that was a great unknown history.
This whole other side of the wine world,
it has been told in academic tomes
but it hadn't really been told so much
in sorta popular books.
And so I just think
there's such a rich history in California.
So much of it has not been explored.
And so that's sort of what gets me going.
And that's been what I've learned the most
that I can combine these
two skills that I have
in a fun way.
- I agree, I think that
the history of our country
has been told very much
through an East Coast filter.
And most of the historians
are on the East Coast.
So there's still a lot of material left
here on the West Coast.
- [Frances] Yeah.
- Well, with that, let's
turn to the audience
and see what questions
we may have for you.
- Well, before we get questions.
I'd invite everybody to
thank France and Deirdre
for an absolutely fascinating
discussion.
(audience applauding)
I thought I knew a fair
amount about the topic,
but I realized that I knew almost nothing.
(chuckles)
We'll take questions for
about 10 minutes or so
if we have that many questions.
And then we, as was mentioned before,
we have a reception at the
back of the auditorium.
And that, of course, will
afford everybody the opportunity
to ask more informal questions.
So, with that, I invite
anyone who has questions
to please come forward.
- [Audience Member] Please
talk about climate change
on the vineyards.
- Sure, the question is will
we talk about climate change
on the vineyards.
I think nobody knows
exactly what's gonna happen.
But as the climate warms up,
that diurnal difference between
hot days and cool nights
is certainly gonna diminish
in Napa and Sonoma.
That will affect the
quality of the grapes.
And so presumably the wine
industry might move north.
Though, of course, there
a lot of scientists
who are experimenting and
trying to create grapes
that will be able to still do well
even if the climate is hotter.
But I think the drought has
had an affect on California.
Certainly last year, the
yields were much lower
because the plants were more stressed out.
And I think they're probably
gonna do okay this year.
But definitely climate
change is a very major worry
for grape growers and wine makers.
- [Audience Member] I
wanted to ask if you could
share some of the history about
University of California at Berkeley being
the university farm and
later one Davis becoming our
university farm.
Just how viticulture came to be a part of
the body of knowledge of the
University of California.
- So the question is sort of
how did viticulture evolve in the halls
of academia in California.
So of course the original
and only university,
public university, in
California was here at Berkeley
for a very long time.
And we--
- And Isaias Hellman
was a regent for--
- Yes, he was a regent
for--
- A long period.
- 38 years he was a regent, I believe.
So there was a man, I think
his name was Mr. Bioletti
who headed up a very important
department at UC Berkeley
that studied wine.
And that, in itself, is a
very interesting history,
because he brought an academic
perspective to making wine.
And he had his supporters.
But there were a lot of businessmen
who fought, like his approach towards wine
was ridiculous and unnecessary.
And those supporters eventually convinced
the legislature to unfund
him in a lot of ways.
And so once Davis was founded,
the whole wine-making,
the study of wine and stuff
was moved up to UC Davis.
So really from the very start,
Berkeley has been very involved
in trying to create better grapes,
studying the conditions under
which grapes flourished,
sort of measuring the
temperatures of different areas
in California to determine climates
and all sorts of things.
So it's been very, very critical
but politics have also played a role
in how those kind of
departments have done.
- [Audience Member] I seem to remember
that there's a connection
with the Hellman name
to the Ehrman Mansion in West Lake Tahoe.
Is it the same Hellman family?
- Yes, so the question
is there's a connection
between the Hellmans and
the Ehrmans in Tahoe.
So Isaias Hellman, who I
write about in Towers of Gold,
he built a beautiful
house on the western shore
of California, of Lake Tahoe,
called Sugar Pine Point, he named it.
And after he died, his
daughter inherited it.
And her name was Florence Hellman-Ehrman.
She was married to Sidney Ehrman.
So the place has something
called the Ehrman Mansion on it.
So that's the answer.
- [Deirdre] It's a state park now?
- It's a state park, yes.
So, yeah, it was taken by
eminent domain by California
in 1968 and people were
very upset about it.
But I think in retrospect
it was a good thing,
because now there's two
miles of open shoreline
for everyone to enjoy.
- [Deirdre] Yeah, great.
- [Audience Member] You've described
the cross-section of the
Jewish history of California.
Is that really the California history?
It seems like such a large part of it,
and yet Jews were such a small
part of the population here.
So I'm wondering whether
we're simply seeing
a focus on that from your discussion.
Obviously, you've researched it.
Or whether it was as big as it sounds.
And if it was as big as it sounds,
how did it get so big?
- That's a very good question.
Yeah, I don't know
(Deirdre chuckles)
how to answer that.
Maybe, yeah, Jews are
a very small percentage
of the population in California.
But perhaps they had an outside influence
certainly in the early days of California,
just because of the tremendous
financial success they had
and how they spent their money
and their philanthropic endeavors.
I mean, we could be talking about
Irish history up here, too,
and there would be a lot
to say about Irish history
or Chinese history.
It's just that I happened
to have written about it,
that's why it's the focus
of this conversation.
- [Audience Member]
And a related question.
One block in San Francisco,
with multiple residents
from Reckendorf, Germany, all born
at the same period of time,
all raised in the same town of 900,
all find their way here eventually,
all are monumental names in
the history of California.
They're wonderfully successful.
They have families that were
wonderfully successful for generations.
But the starting point is this
little spot in Reckendorf.
What in the water there--
(audience and speakers laughing)
I'm wondering whether
it's just the fact that
Europeans in 1850 knew what
the future of the United States
in 1851 was gonna look like
because we were still living in 1820.
- Yes.
- I didn't get the last part.
- [Audience Member]
Well, the United States
was behind Europe in terms of its cultural
and economic and political and
artistic development.
- You know, I think
this touches, if I may
throw something in here,
on the advantages of being
discriminated against
in some situations,
that when Frances discussed the fact that
Jews could not own property
in Germany, were not citizens.
And in other central and eastern
European countries as well.
So they were motivated to emigrate,
whereas other young men who
would have good prospects
in Europe perhaps wouldn't
have been as motivated.
After all, it's mainly
the poor who emigrate.
- [Deirdre] Right.
- But in this case it was
well educated middle-class Jews who--
- [Audience Member]
Except Isais was what, 16.
How well educated can he be?
Or was he?
Was he high school European educated?
- Yeah.
- I mean, they weren't exactly middle cla,
I mean, they had the money to
send their children overseas.
Yeah, but actually the middle-class Jews,
when restrictions were
loosened in Germany,
starting in 1860s, many of
them went to the cities.
And they didn't come to America.
But the question about
the water in Reckendorf
is a really good one.
I did find out in my research that
at least eight men who
came from Reckendorf
became multi-millionaires
in the 19th Century.
- [Deirdre] Did they all
go to the same school?
- They probably all went to
the same little Jewish school.
(chuckles) That teacher might've
been the glue, who knows?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, that would be interesting.
- [Audience Member] Eight
Jews from Reckendorf.
- Right.
- Eight.
- Probably went
to the same synagogue, too.
- The same synagogue.
- Yes, there's only
one synagogue.
- I mean, there's probably
somewhere back there,
there's probably some figure
that would be interesting to discover.
You know, one might guess that
there would be some educator
or rabbi who played a role
in their formative times.
I just would comment one thing about your
saying how do you get into proportion,
how much is the Jewish
history of California
the history of California,
or how much did Jews create California,
that I don't think we can give
a definitive answer to that.
But what I would add to this is that
I think the story of the Jewish role
in the creation of California
actually was a little-known story.
And so I think Frances',
one of the importance
of Frances' work, has been
in surfacing that story.
And then perhaps it's for
other people to try to
get it into proportion,
or say the importance of that
story relative to others.
But it's a story that
really had not been told.
There's a wonderful documentary movie.
And I know you played a
role and you're in it,
by a woman named Jackie Krentzman
that's called American Jerusalem.
And American Jerusalem is San Francisco.
And it is another attempt,
and a very recent one,
just within the past two years,
a few years, but it was on PBS,
to tell that untold story
that the Jews of San Francisco
did play an important role,
maybe not the all-important role,
but an important role in the development
of the economy and the culture
that we are still living in today.
It's very, very much the
heirs of the institutions
that they created.
So, yes?
- [Audience Member] Hi, thank you.
Just moving up to the modern day.
I wanted to ask you, Frances,
about given the focus on
the HarvEst lecture series
and its focus on women,
if you might speak to your own experience
as a prominent woman author
and as co-founder of Berkeleyside,
and then also perhaps to touch on,
because I'm curious about it,
women in the wine industry today.
- Yes, so I do.
One of my main characters
in my book is a woman.
Her name is Delia Viader.
She had grown up in Argentina.
Her family had Spanish
roots and French roots.
She is one of the first really prominent
female wine makers in Napa.
She lost about four-and-a-half
million dollars worth of wine
in that fire, she was uninsured.
This woman has an incredible spirit
and an incredible drive.
And she was able to recover
from that devastating financial loss.
And so there are a number of
female wine makers in Napa.
I mean, it's been a place where
women have thrived as much as men.
And there are a lot of iconic names.
So, anyway.
- You know, I'm glad that
you mentioned Berkeleyside,
because we didn't get to that.
But Frances is one of the founders
and she's a reporter and editor
for Berkeleyside, an online
local, hyper-local newspaper,
or news site that I think we can all
be very grateful for.
And it plays a really important role.
And I hope if any of you have not,
don't look at it, you'll
Google it and go look at it.
So, thank you very much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)